elle est brutale et explosive mais tout
indique que l'actuelle vague de micron
sera plus courte que les vagues
précédentes
absolument on a vu à travers le monde de
rêve et 3 donc montée vertigineuse et
une descente aussi rappelé plusieurs des
premiers pays touchés par au micron
rapporte la même chose en afrique du sud
là où tout a commencé
on enregistre une chute très près de 70%
des cas au royaume uni également
durement touché une baisse de 14% et en
france on commence à respirer un peu
mieux on pourrait s'attendre à être
bientôt une forme de pique mais est ce
que cette une est ce que c'est un pic
encore une fois ou est ce que c'est un
plateau ça je ne peux pas vous le dire
aujourd'hui même aux états unis où les
cas se comptent par millions les experts
sont plus optimistes
en fait ce les vagues précédentes
mettaient en moyenne 2 - pu avant
d'atteindre le sommet
la vague au micro et parvis deux fois
plus rapidement
essentiellement en raison de la
transmissibilité exceptionnelle du
variant un virus si content à jules qui
se fait pas très rapidement dans la
population
ils vont éventuellement se soucier
manqué de personnes a infecté de québec
qui est frappé par micron depuis la mi
décembre suivraient la même trajectoire
il ya une confirmation n'a pas des
experts que le nombre d'infections donc
le nombre de corps se stabilise c'est
dans la région de montréal que la
situation devrait s'améliorer en premier
c'est vraiment montréal affichent
cependant c'est bien on peut se réjouir
au québec on pourrait espérer en effet
que cette diminution là va commencer à
noter puisque on va se retrouver
dans les prochains jours semaines avoir
une diminution qui est significative il
faut rappeler qu'il existe toujours un
délai entre la diminution du nombre de
cas et la baisse du nombre
d'hospitalisations
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal